plus d'une personne sur cinq est menacée
de pauvreté ou d'exclusion sociale dans
l'Union européenne derrière ce chiffre
il y a des individus en souffrance cette
réalité est insupportable face à ce
constat il est capital de pouvoir
s'appuyer sur des régimes de revenus
minimum robuste c'est une mesure de
justice sociale le Conseil a adopter sa
recommandation sur le sujet il s'agit
d'un instrument non contraignant pour
les États membres Monsieur le
Commissaire je vous appelle à présenter
une directive sur le revenu minimum
cette directive doit pouvoir assurer le
niveau adéquat des revenus minimum dans
chaque pays pour que chacun puisse vivre
dignement elle doit aussi coordonner nos
approches pour renforcer les politiques
de retour vers l'emploi c'est notre
responsabilité d'élus d'arriver à une
Europe plus juste qui promeut partout la
dimension émancipatrice du travail mais
qui est toujours accompagnent ceux qui
en ont le plus besoin